peu plus
lancé en mai 1960 le paquebot france va
s'achever ces aménagements à saint
nazaire ses deux cheminées dont la
hauteur est celle d'un immeuble de six
étages de quoi loger 50 personnes
apparaissent aujourd'hui débarrasser de
leurs échafaudages à trois semaines des
essais en mai et le 3 février le plus
long paquebot du monde voguera vers la
mairie
[Musique]
on la septième fois cette année le
président de la république a fait les
honneurs de l'elysée à un chef d'état de
l'afrique d'expression française
monsieur hubert maga président de la
république du dahomey haute de la france
pour trois jours le coeur de nos deux
pays bas au même rythme avait dit à son
arrivée le président hubert maga ce sont
ces paroles qu'il a voulu traduire en se
recueillant sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu
[Musique]
et à travers cette visite du dahomey à
paris la foule des champs elysées a pu
évoquer l'amitié d'un pays vieillit à la
france depuis 1895 et à qui elle a donné
voici un an l'indépendance
m
le palais de chaillot a vu la rentrée
parisienne de minou drouet qui poète sd
longtemps consacré n'a pas dédaigné de
s'intéresser aux côtés de l'ambassadeur
d'italie à la nouvelle revue tout
l'univers cas baptisé catherine langeais
il faut dire que cette première
encyclopédie hebdomadaire tout en
couleurs qui s'adresse aux enfants de 8
à 15 ans réalise la noble ambition
d'instruire en distrayant
et côté du peintre jean gabriel domergue
promu président de jury de robert rocca
et maître henry torrès de pierre du dans
on devait retrouver minou drouet preuve
que paris est petit on devrait aussi
retrouver catherine langeais qui a remis
les palmes d'or du roman d'espionnage
1961 à serge la forêt
avec une chèvre symbole de la
sorcellerie capelette évidemment le
titre de son livre le temps des sorciers
norris est devenu pour deux jours une
capitale la capitale de picasso vingt
mille amis admirateurs aux fanatiques du
pain sont tout simplement venus lui
souhaiter un bon anniversaire avec
cantate fanfare feu d'artifice et
discours bien entendeur avec
naturellement aussi une exposition
picasso il y est venu avec sa femme
jacqueline tout gentiment en blouson
noir au milieu des bousculades et des
acclamations et avec tout le monde il a
regardé ses toiles celle d'hier et
d'avant-hier et celle d'aujourd'hui on
sait que des toiles il en a dans les
plus grands musées du monde que le
moindre tableau signé de son nom vaut
des millions on sait que sa première
exposition date de 1897 et que la doire
de ce peintre étonnant qui a passé sa
vie à désintégrer la peinture est
vieille d'au moins 40 ans on sait aussi
qu'il en a 80 aujourd'hui et qu'il est
toujours aussi jeanne
et en souvenir de cette corrida qui la
peint et repeints on lui en a offert une
avec dominguin qui est son ami
c'est vallauris qui a fêté son
anniversaire ou plutôt le monde entier à
vallauris c'est à dire ces millions de
gens qui ne peuvent plus voir le monde
de la même façon depuis que picasso un
jour a commencé atteint
le monde est il besoin de le dire vit
des temps troublés dans berlin nouvelles
tensions la police de monsieur olbrich
persistant à vouloir contrôler les
militaires alliées en civil au passage
de la ligne frontière le commandement
usa a décidé de les faire accompagner en
cas de difficulté par des soldats en
armes c'est ce qui s'est passé à
plusieurs reprises et notamment pour le
passage en zone est de l'adjoint du
général clé ces vexations répétées
faisant suite à des mesures prises en
dehors de tout accord des quatre
puissances occupantes ont provoqué une
tension accrue les troupes ont été mises
en état d' alerte et de chaque côté de
la frontière chars américains et chars
soviétiques se sont fait face au point
de passage de la friedrichstrasse
pendant plus de 12 heures
depuis la tension s'est relâchée les
charges ont été retirées mais le
problème de berlin demeure
[Musique]
à
ciudad robinho c'est un autre spectacle
la capitale de la république dominicaine
continue à vivre des semaines agitées à
plusieurs reprises des manifestations
d'étudiants se sont heurtés à la
réaction sans douceur de la police
gouvernementale
il apparaît malgré l' influence durable
de l'ex dictateur que la succession de
tours îlots dont l'un des fils a pris la
place est très controversée il ajoute à
cela la proximité de cuba
e
le nord de l'angola où s'était étendu la
rébellion anti portugaise a été ces
derniers mois le théâtre d'importantes
opérations militaires qui semblent avoir
abouti à une réoccupation total de cette
région difficile dont la brousse et la
montagne faisait un réduit idéal pour la
guérilla le dernier épisode la prise du
village de nambuangongo qui était devenu
le pc validation a été le plus décisif
d'une campagne particulièrement du les
unités portugaise on tue à lutter autant
avec les difficultés du pays et du
climat qu'avec les noyaux de robert
l'opération de pedra vers des collines
de 300 mètres d'altitude qui émerge de
la forêt tropicale devait être le point
crucial de cette avance qui a permis
l'occupation de nambuangongo laissé en
ruines par ses occupants les populations
qui avaient fui leurs foyers rentrer
maintenant peu à peu et on peut croire
que les mouvements militaires de
quelqu'un vers bir ont pris fin mais le
leader nationaliste holden roberto qui
dirige la rébellion depuis léopoldville
ne désarment pas
milieu de cette période trouble nous
vivons l'amélioration des techniques
militaires n'apporte pas il faut bien le
dire une très grande consolation que le
ministre de la guerre britannique
monsieur john profumo se voit présenter
un conte mobile au déploiement
automatique de la meilleure facture ne
nous emplit que d'une joie mesurée
et la découverte du super chars shift
end le dernier né des usines d'armement
47 tonnes avec canon à performance tenue
secrète n'est pour personne un élément
d'enthousiastes
le confort du blessé a en tout cas fait
de sérieux progrès avec ses doubles
civière qui glisse sur un matelas d'air
comprimé il en existe d'ailleurs une
version à main pour blesser salle qui
laisse loin derrière elle tous les
brancards de naguère a longtemps dû
s'il avait été un tout petit peu
superstitieux les 13 jockey du grand
steeple de tchécoslovaquie n'aurait
peut-être pas pris le départ de
l'épreuve et il serait sans doute bien
fait je me sens la curd oeuvre les 6900
mètres du parcours sont jalonnées de
bien d'autres obstacles sont franchis
tant bien que mal et plutôt mal que bien
mais l'essentiel n'est-il pas de rester
sur le taux du cheval
et maintenant qu'on est dedans
continuez
si on peut se dérober de toute façon le
cheval n'a pas d'avis à donner
le plus étonnant c'est qu'il y ait tout
de même à vainqueur à l'arrivée
[Rires]
pas question de rêver devant la beauté
du paysage ici dans ces montagnes du
canada on prépare l'avenir un avenir qui
n'est pas très rose il est vrai
ces montagnards ce sont des sauveteurs
de la gendarmerie royale canadienne qui
effectue un exercice
une nouveauté dans leur système au lieu
d'utiliser des cordages il emploie des
câbles d'acier qui mis bout à bout
peuvent atteindre près de 500 mètres de
longueur
avec ses câbles et aux moyens de poulies
on peut parfaitement descendra blessé le
long d'une paroi abrupte
bien traverser une gorge ou une crevasse
[Musique]
pour les cas graves il a même été prévu
une civière
[Musique]
la princesse margaret et lorsque
n'ordonne son époux plus connu sous le
nom de tony n'ont pas déçu l'angleterre
ce matin là la foule stationné devant
clarence house et les cameramen avaient
ajusté leurs téléobjectifs pour le film
est d'ailleurs que deux fenêtres
des fenêtres derrière lesquelles se
déroulait un événement de première
importance un nouveau vicomte venait de
naître à l'angleterre aux accents
débonnaire de la musique de la garde
fils de la princesse margaret
le vicomte linley de no man's est le
cinquième dans l'ordre de succession au
trône donc à
[Musique]
alger comme le reste de l'algérie
attendait dans l'anxiété le 1er novembre
dont le fln avait décidé de faire une
journée de manifestations on était allé
avec un jour d'avancé se recueillir sur
les tombes des disparus qu'allait être
ce 7e anniversaire de l'insurrection au
matin la casse va présenter des rues
vides seulement animé par la marge d'une
patrouille
l'effectif du service d'ordre à alger
avait été porté à 35 mille hommes si
bien que les cortèges une fois formés en
ont été réduits à tourner en rond dans
les quartiers fermées empêchent composé
d'ailleurs en majeure partie de femmes
d'enfants et de jeunes gens
partout la possibilité de heurts entre
manifestants et européens avaient été
évitées et les défilés exhibant les
couleurs fln se sont essoufflés dans la
matinée pour disparaître dans l'après
midi
à diar el mahçoul les premiers
manifestants apparaissait à 7h30
plusieurs centaines qu'ils allaient
tourner en rond dans la cité
et portent les blindés fermer la route à
toute tentative d'étendre les
manifestations dans toute l'algérie ce
1er novembre devait toutefois se solder
par 77 morts et 140 blessés mais à alger
comme dans les autres grandes villes
d'algérie l'affrontement entre les deux
communautés a été évité
la capitale du honduras britannique
belize n'existe plus ou à peu près des
rues encore noyé sous les eaux de rares
habitations encore partiellement debout
des gens hagards c'est le spectacle
qu'offre une cité de 30000 habitants
après le passage de l'ouragan rafting
pillage menace d'épidémie n'ont fait
qu'accroître une situation beaucoup plus
désastreuse que les premières
informations erronées ou mensongère ne
l'avait laissé imaginer
l'évacuation annoncé n'ayant pas eu lieu
on compterait un grand nombre de morts
belize en effet aurait été détruite à
75%
[Applaudissements]
325 mille habitants à l'intérieur un
million ou dehors c'est cela la corse du
moins selon les corses eux mêmes et il
est de fait que les corses forme de
véritables colonies une sorte d'action
ne prétend aussi qu'en france le
policier est corse et l'adjudant et le
douanier le gardien de prison et tant
d'autres fonctionnaient il y à du faux
et du vrai tous ces corps se ne restent
pas isolé ils se voient se retrouvent
restent unis en dépit des différences de
situations racontent les mêmes histoires
et font les mêmes gestes
voilà et puis à l'heure de la retraite
il se retrouve au pays devant les mêmes
vert avec les mêmes histoires et les
mêmes silence
au soir de leur vie ils ont retrouvé ce
qu'ils n'ont jamais oublié leurs
vieilles pierres et leurs vieilles rues
ce décor tracé à grands traits durs d'un
pays qui n'a rien à exporter que ses
enfants ils retrouvent leur cimetière
car un bon corse ne peut bien dormir que
dans sa terre de corse au milieu des
noms qui ne s'évadent jamais ils
retrouvent leur mât qui leur ferait leur
montagne ses paysages qui n'ont à offrir
que leur beauté comment ici gagner sa
vie laperne nourrit que de maigres
troupeaux et les oliviers qu'on s'est
forcé de cultiver en terrasse ne paye
pas l'effort qu'ils exigent quant à
l'industrie at il vu celui-là une seule
cheminées des usines dans le ciel de son
île où il a vu le ramassage des
châtaignes
rien d'agricole et rien d'un nul il faut
faire venir les trois cinquièmes de ce
qui sert à la vie grevé bien entendu des
frais supplémentaires de transport
retour à vide compris puisqu'il n'y a
rien à exporter ce qui pèse sur les prix
on a pu rire de cette prime d'insularité
demandé par les corses mais distille ne
sommes nous pas en france
qui hier aurait tenté ici une aventure
industrielle ou commerciale
la ville de sartène une sous préfecture
n'a même pas de gare
cas unique en france aucune voie ferrée
ni conduit et la vieille ville peut bien
souhaité la bienvenue à ses visiteurs
hindi débarqueront pas par trains
entiers
et certaines est un exemple extrême mais
les chemins de fer sont rares et il faut
d'un rendement suffisant on les a même
condamné ce qui a suscité des
protestations véhémentes la corse demain
pourrait être le seul département
français à ignorer le chemin de fer
quant à la route trop souvent resserré
elle se perd en et andres dans les
cantons perdus réseau parcimonieux elle
joint les villes mais par des fils si
ténue on dirait que la corse a été
oubliée pendant des décades de progrès
matériel comme elle l'avait été par des
siècles d'isolement on dirait qu'elle se
contente d'être avec ses paysages qu'ils
peuvent compter parmi les plus beaux du
monde une patrie pour petits retraités
on dirait qu'elle a toutes épuisées avec
le souvenir dans lequel ajaccio s'endort
chaque soir depuis un siècle celui d'un
petit lieutenant d'artillerie
mais il faut revoir ce problème à la
lumière d'aujourd'hui
ah ah
les caprices de la nature qui laisse
faute de pluie des régions dépérir de
sécheresse quand d'autres souffrent
d'inondations sont peut-être sur le
point d'être corrigés c'est dans cette
perspective en tout cas que se situe
l'expérience de lannemezan où le
professeur d'essence a installé son
météo tron l'appareil a fabriqué les
nuages le mét et autres ont une centaine
de brûlures reliés par 700 mètres de
tuyaux à des réservoirs contenant trois
pommes de gasoil en somme le modèle
géant du dispositif employés dans les
chaudières à mazout
l'allumage évidemment est un peu plus
compliqué et c'est tout mais l'histoire
ne s'arrête pas là une énorme source de
chaleur se trouvent ainsi créée elle va
amorcer le processus de formation d'un
cumulus qui soit dit en passant n'aura
rien à voir avec les fumées parasites
dégagée par la combustion
l'air surchauffé aspirant l'air humide
ambiant à 20 km à la ronde va s'élever à
100 ou 200 kilomètres à l'heure
jusqu'aux zones d'air froid et sec ou va
s'opérer la condensation qui fera naître
un cumulus
désormais donc un cumulus fenêtre là où
l'homme en aura décidé c'est là la
révolution apportée par les expériences
de lannemezan où les radars spéciaux
permettent de suivre la formation du
nuage il suffit alors d'une projection
vieux dur d'argent sur ce nuage pour le
faire tomber rampe lui
la première étape d expérience s'est
ainsi révélé concluant le mettais autres
on a réussi à remplacer la nature ou
plutôt à lui forcer la main demain
l'homme de science pourra laisser la
place aux faiseurs de pluie et il sera
enfin possible de produire à volonté à
la terre la plus sèche sa part
d'humidité et de fertilité
on attendait beaucoup du combat de deux
des meilleurs poids moyens français
marcel picot culotte à parements blancs
et hippolyte annexes adversaire d'un
soir au palais des sports ap ap c'est un
match sans étincelle qu'ont assisté les
6000 spectateurs parisiens et pourtant
pigou et annexes sont les deux poids
moyens français les plus spectaculaires
ce qui attire la grande foule
à vrai dire le spectacle était surtout
dans la salle où se trouvaient mais les
joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football et vedette de cinéma
hippolyte annexes et plus brouillon
qu'efficace pendant son dynamisme fini
par être payant trois fois pigou va à
terre au cours du huitième round
lorsque pigou se reprend il est beaucoup
trop tard et c'est très justement
canucks remportent ce combat
il aura sans doute beaucoup plus de mal
devant son futur adversaire et sugar
robinson l'inusable quadragénaire
nous aussi nous avons des arguments à
faire valoir dans les concours de beauté
et nous ne manquons pas totalement
d'éloquence à preuve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
j'ai toujours sensible à de tels
arguments
[Musique]
alors monsieur ne soyez pas jaloux
alors
cela vous laisse rêveur
enfin un connaisseur
ah ah
la botte
et bien c'est comme cela que l'on
devient monsieur europe 1961 ne vous en
déplaise
11 novembre le général de gaulle était
au rendez vous de la piété nationale
devant le tombeau du soldat inconnu
entouré des anciens combattants des deux
guerres françaises et alliées le chef de
l'état a commémoré le souvenir de la
victoire de 1918 et en même temps le
souvenir de tous ceux qui tombèrent sur
les champs de bataille
quarante trois ans ont passé depuis la
fin de la grande guerre 43 ans qui ont
vu bien d'autres bouleversements mais le
premier cataclysme mondial fut si énorme
et entraîne attentes conséquence que
près d'un demi-siècle s'est écoulé sans
le faire oublier
[Musique]
le célèbre pavillon de flore quitte
enfin le service des finances de l'état
pour se mettre à celui des beaux-arts
monsieur baumgartner en a remis
solennellement les clés à monsieur andré
malraux ministre des affaires
culturelles
[Musique]
le pavillon de flore va être aménagée
pour recevoir les collection de
sculptures des 18 et 19ème siècle du
musée du lourd
la fondation de la vocation dont le jury
réunit à la fois des hommes de lettres
des journalistes des publicistes des
chefs d'entreprise a remis pour la
deuxième fois ses bourses annuelles 26
jeunes gens et jeunes filles ont ainsi
reçu un chèque d'un million d'anciens
francs qui doit leur permettre de
s'aventurer dans de meilleures
conditions dans le métier qu'ils ont
choisi d'exercer tel est en effet le but
de cette oeuvre aider les révocations à
s'épanouir
le ministre de la santé publique
monsieur joseph fontanet s'est vu
présenter le timbre de la nouvelle
campagne anti tuberculeuse 61,62
traitement bien suivi guérison assuré
tel est le thème de cette campagne qui
vise à mettre en garde des malades
contre les dangers auxquels les expose
le manque de persévérance la tuberculose
peut être guéri mais on doit savoir que
seule la cure en sanatorium offre toutes
les garanties d'une guérison totale
permettant un reclassement définitif
dans la vie sociale
[Musique]
cette paire de corse dont la semaine
dernière nous disions qu'il fallait
revoir ses problèmes à la lumière
d'aujourd'hui il ne faut tout de même
pas la simplifier au point d'en faire le
tableau traditionnel qu'on regarde avec
une affection décourager d'accord c'est
un diptyque dont le premier volet sans
doute et celui du criminel inconnue le
catenaccio traînant ses chaînes sous la
cagoule d'un penny temps du vendredi
saint des vieilles femmes en tissu noir
des ruelles et des maquis
[Musique]
il ya aussi du nouveau en corse du
nouveau c'est à dire des projets des
promesses et des expériences sur cette
terre trop bavard pour nourrir ses
enfants on cherche aujourd'hui de
nouveaux champs dans la plaine orientale
des français venus d'algérie et de
tunisie se sont lancés à la conquête
agricole du pays des fermes modèles se
sont élevées et l'on peut imaginer
qu'avec ses récupérations on pourra
compter en corse 80 mille hectares
cultivés c'est à dire le dixième du
salle de lives c'est pour ainsi dire une
corse nouvelle qui est en train de
naître sans doute cette agriculture ne
sera jamais de taille à faire vivre la
corse mais il lui reste le merveilleux
décor qu'on peut exploiter en y faisant
venir les touristes dans ce domaine il
faut créer l'infrastructure opel et
route et de ce côté aussi des progrès
sont en cours la rénovation des hôtels
est sérieusement encourager même de
beaux hôtels d'un parfait modernisme se
sont élevées
[Musique]
et
déjà aussi le problème routier a été
sérieusement étudiée un réseau de routes
touristiques est ou en projet ou en
cours d'exécution et le voyageur de
demain ne se posera plus la question
d'amener avec lui sa voiture il s'agit
de refaire la corse à l'échelle moderne
or l'avenir de la corse c'est peut être
simplement de pouvoir montrer ses
calanques et ses vieilles vignes et là
dessus son ciel dès dimanche
[Musique]
c'est à cette force avec ses problèmes
avec aussi ses espérances a cette force
qui n'avait pas reçu la visite d'un
président de la république depuis 40 ans
que le général de gaulle a choisi de
consacrer les premières journées de son
15e voyages en france et bastia comme
ajaccio nous ont réservé le même accueil
un accueil tel que l'avait défini à
l'avancé des personnalités de l'île
chaleureux sans arrière pensée comme
savent le faire les portes et c'est
devant cette foule que le chef de l'état
devait rouvrir le dossier algérien si
personne n'y met deux préalables et nous
n'émettrons aucun la conversation va
s'engager d'un jour à l'eau
la visite du port de marseille a marqué
le début de la quatrième et dernière
journée du voyage présidentiel qui après
la corse avait conduit le chef de l'état
à travers le var et les bouches-du-rhône
à marseille porte de la méditerranée
ouverte sur l'afrique du nord le général
de gaulle devait évoquer à nouveau le
règlement de l'affairé algérienne il
devait le faire devant une foule immense
je déclare que la solution du problème
algérien sait que l'algérie dispose de
son destin c'est qu'une coopération soit
établie entre l'algérie nouvelle et la
france
[Musique]
pendant 48 heures l'incendié a fait rage
sur les collines de santa monica le
quartier chic de rely woods deux
brasiers séparés par une distance de 17
km se précipitaient à la rencontre l'un
de l'autre sur un front de 15 km 24
bombardier ou répandu des teintes de
borat les sinistrés star politique comme
monsieur nixon 12 ha ha
cinématographique s'efforçait avec les
moyens du bord de défendre leurs
habitations aidé par 3000 pompiers et
1000 soldats hollywood pour une fois
dans sa vie factice a été confronté avec
un incendie authentique ces menaces ces
périls et ces désastres
à
aujourd'hui que le danger est passé on
peut évaluer l'ensemble des dégâts 200
villas sont détruites avec tout le luxe
qu'elle contenait peut-être 50 milliards
d'anciens francs réduits en fumée
[Musique]
comme chaque année moscou a fêté
l'anniversaire de la révolution
d'octobre par un immense défilé
populaire sur la place rouge la fin
officielle du culte de staline a produit
cet effet que l'éffigie de prod chef a
remplacé celle du dictateur défunt
et dans la tribune officielle qui
surmonte le monument d'où le corps de
staline a été enlevée le maître du
kremlin entouré de ses invités étrangers
et des membres du gouvernement a présidé
cette manifestation de masse désormais
classique
[Musique]
détail curieux le maréchal vorochilov
ancien président de l'urss malgré son
humble autocritique au récent congrès
n'a pas été admis à la tribune
officielle
il
[Musique]
le mur qui coupent berlin en 2 coupes en
2d famille prétexte d'un grave incident
de la vie internationale il est en même
temps à l'origine de drames familiaux
chaque dimanche on peut voir des groupes
de part et d'autre de cette barrière
aujourd'hui infranchissable se ferme
signe ou plus simplement chercher au
loin un visage amis
triste rencontre où seuls les yeux
peuvent parler
devant l'entrée aujourd'hui muré du
cimetière sainte hedwidge on dépose ce
qu'on ne peut plus déposer comme hier
sur les tombes ne mur ne sépare pas que
les vivants
dans l'équipe de bulgarie maillot blanc
la rencontre devant la france à sofia
c'était le match de la dernière chance
le match qu'il fallait gagner à
n'importe quel prix les bulgares et y
ont mis le prix en effet ils n'ont pas
hésité à appuyer leur action avec une
certaine rudesse sous l'oeil
bienveillant de l' arbitre un arbitre
que les français ne sont pas prêts
d'oublier
au début du match on craignait le pire
pour l'équipe de france a tort sans
doute puisque toutes les attaques
bulgare devait apporter sur une défense
très efficace
pour les français une seule consigne le
match nul à la mi-temps tous les espoirs
leur sont encore permis
à plusieurs reprises en seconde mi temps
ils ont même le but au bout du pied une
combinaison guillas muller fugazi sur
coup franc et près d'aboutir mais
l'arbitré lui est bien décidé à offrir
la victoire à la bulgarie à une minute
de la fin à bulgare commettent une faute
dans le camp français qu'à cela ne
tienne coup franc pour la bulgarie le
coup franc ne donne rien pas de chance
il arbitre on va leur jouer à ce petit
jeu les bulgares finissent par gagner
mais on se demande encore ce corps
eiffel arbitres si les bulgares n'avait
pas profité de son cadre
[Applaudissements]
ce sera une nouvelle date dans les
annales de saint nazaire capitale des
constructions navales que celle du
premier départ du paquebot france dont
on pourra venir demain qu'il est le plus
beau paquebot du monde tirait par-ci
remorqueur le g1 a pris le large pour
ses essais en mer qui le mèneront au
havre son futur port d'attache pour ce
premier voyage le paquebot emporté 700
hommes d'équipage et 700 ingénieurs et
ouvriers qui achèveront pendant cette
croisière les travaux d'aménagement
tout sera prêt pour la première
traversée le havre new york
au sahara le gaz continuent de brûler au
puits de gassi touil une flamme de 200 m
15 millions de mètres cubes qui
s'évanouissent chaque jour les 860
mètres de la tige du forage éjecté gît
sur le sable fondu tordu
l'intense chaleur dégagée créer un puits
sans appel d'air l'air chaud aspirer
semble couler et chose est un homme dans
ce pays de la sécheresse la torche de
gassi touil il fabrique des nuages
l'homme restera t-il impuissant à
réduire cette envie qui de l'avis des
experts pourrait durer cent ans
de même que le 11 novembre il avait été
salué les morts de la guerre le général
de gaulle est allé rendre visite à
d'autres victimes les grands blessés
dans cette institution nationale des
invalides on ne le sait pas assez vives
ou reçoivent les soins nécessaires des
mutilés des blessés d'hier et
d'avant-hier
[Musique]
l'effort que vous accomplissez pour
surmonter votre douleur est un exemple
auxquels je rends hommage leur a dit le
chef de l'état c'est ainsi que vous
continuez à servir je vous remercie au
nom de la france
à la garderie sur var le chef de l'état
français avait rendez vous avec l'abbé
fulbert youlou président de la
république du congo 8e chefs d'état de
l'afrique d'expression française à être
reçu à paris
il ya tant de liens qui unissent nos
deux pays disait en accueillant le
général de gaulle ces paroles devaient
trouver leurs prolongements à l'elysée
un peu plus tard où les deux hommes se
retrouvaient en tête à tête pour un
premier entretien
cette visite est à la fois un espoir et
une conclusion brazzaville on s'en
souvient est à l'origine du grand
mouvement français qui devaient opérer
l'évolution des pays d'afrique noire
[Musique]
la reine elizabeth et le duc d'edimbourg
ont déchaîné les tam-tams sur
l'aérodrome d'accra capitale du ghana où
ils étaient les autres du président de
trauma il faut dire que le ghana n'avait
rien négligé pour faire un succès de la
visite royale à commencer par la parade
militaire qui comportait un trooping the
colour d'importation très réussi
le folklore autochtone a bien entendu
été lui aussi mis à contribution au
cours de ce voyage qui avait failli être
annulée au dernier moment pour des
motifs de sécurité et qui sait en dépit
des pronostics révélé triomphal
allez
l'heure h à sonné pour les concours dont
philippe herria s'est fait le porte
parole pour 261 a été attribué à
monsieur jean cau pour son roman la
pitié de dieu au troisième tour en même
temps c'est la tradition était attribué
le prix renaudot et les dix n'ont eu que
quelques pas à faire pour féliciter avec
les journalistes l'heureux lauréat du
renaudot roger bordier
le mérite unis a la chance c'est le prix
de miss chine hier secondes de miss
monde aujourd'hui promu à ce titre du
fait du mariage de l'élu au lendemain de
son élection
c'est à paris à l'ambassade de chine que
la nouvelle miss monde a fêté sa
promotion entre miss madagascar miss
hollande et miss france
[Musique]
encore un prix mais d'un autre genre au
cours d'une vente de tableaux anciens
qu'on peut nommer la vente du siècle à
new york le record des prix a été
atteint par un rembrandt aristote
contemplant le buste d'homère qui a
atteint le prix fabuleux 2,1 milliards
150 millions d'anciens francs
on n'avait pas prévu cela il avait peint
pour 500 flore
[Musique]
amy moie maillot foncé culotte blanche
n'ont pas amené le soleil du midi sous
leurs crampons stade bollaert à lens le
soleil était plutôt du côté des joueurs
lensois qui jongle en ce moment avec nos
adversaires au bout d'une demi-heure de
ce petit jeu big ans qui le demi gauche
de lens marque le premier but de son
équipe
et les offensives de lens continue
wisnieski numéro 9 qui jouera peut-être
dans la prochaine équipe de france
coordonne parfaitement les mouvements de
ses attaquants et lens ne va pas tarder
à marquer son second but
à la clé rien ne va plus à nice lens en
effet poursuit ses offensives toujours
avec le même père sans les nîmois ne
savent plus où se placer pour empêcher
leurs adversaires de tirer au but 3 0
pour la paix dans le coin des
supporteurs les nîmois ne font pas le
poids a endurées par les apparences du
moins
[Applaudissements]
dans les dernières minutes
les nîmois à leur tour marqué un but ce
qui n'empêche pas cependant l'équipe
d'être battu par 3 à
le palais des sports parisien alors du
rock and roll ça c'est du son
vague n'a rien inventé ce qu'elle
appelle aujourd'hui rock du temps de
grand papa ça portait déjà un nom on
appelait ça la danse de 5
je vois de la fin
marquer plus quelles que soient les
circonstances si on perd le nord en
revanche pertes l'amérique
la balle se débattant plan pourrait bien
en définitive prendre le pas sur lui
bilan de ces petits festivals 2 millions
de dégâts quelques postes des yeux au
beurre noir et un cimetière de chaises
cassées bref du grand art
pourquoi donc vous en plaindre monsieur
van himst alors vous y est peut-être
pour quelque chose
[Musique]
la séparation entre les deux berlin se
fait plus dur chaque jour par des gestes
multiples la population de berlin-ouest
manifeste sans répit sa colère tout le
long de la barrière qu'elle nomme le mur
de la honte
depuis quelques jours le gouvernement de
bangkok s'est de nouveau renforcé cette
barrière qui interdit totalement l'accès
de la porte de brandebourg un véritable
mur de béton haut de deux mètres doublé
par des chevaux de frise qui rappelle la
ligne siegfried sépare les deux berlin
prétexte officiel accroître la sécurité
de berlin s
[Musique]
à
ces mesures ont suscité une
manifestation de 15 mille jeunes
berlinois de l'ouest qui à la lumière
des torches ont organisé une marche de
protestation contre le mur
[Musique]
là
voici 17,1 dans strasbourg libérer le
général de gaulle était allé célébrer au
milieu de l'armée française remise au
combat l'action héroïque qui avait sauvé
la capitale alsacienne
avec leclerc et avec delattre dans cette
cathédrale que le serment de koufra fixé
comme le but même de la résurrection de
l'armée française il avait entendu le
thé des hommes de la victoire
[Musique]
et puis 17 ans ont passé le clair et de
lattes ont disparu et le général de
gaulle est revenu à strasbourg où il
avait donné rendez vous à trois mille
officiers et sous-officiers venus de
tous les corps d'une armée que les
avatars du temps ont troublé
on peut s'expliquer
et moi-même tout le premier
que dans l'esprit et dans le coeur
de certains soldats
se soit fait jour
d'autres souhaits
et même l'illusion
qu'à force de vouloir
on pourrait ferrand sent que les choses
soient
ce que l'on désire
et le contraire de ce qu'elle chante
mais
dès lors que l'état et la nation ont
choisi leur chemin ce
devoir militaire est fixé une fois pour
toutes
hors de ces règles il n'y à une paix
qu'à voir
que des soldats perdus
des soldats perdus ils ne peuvent pas
laid il n'y a qu'à voir défiler dans le
brouillard de strasbourg cette armée
rénové pour sentir selon les paroles du
chef de l'état la confiance de la france
en elle-même et en son armée
[Musique]
est-ce pour y chercher des leçons des
exemples des raisons de vivre et
d'espérer le monde moderne se retourne
avec tant de curiosité sur le passé
jamais en effet on a fait telle place à
l'archéologie aujourd'hui encore près de
mexico une mission est en train de
mettre à jour une pyramide aztèque
vieille de huit cents ans dans un site
jusqu'ici inexplorés et où les
possibilités de découvertes sont
considérables
cette pyramide de taille modeste n'a
évidemment rien de commun avec les
normes pyramide du soleil haute de 73 m
vieille d'environ 3000 ans et qui est
sans contredit le plus remarquable des
11000 monument aujourd'hui classé de
l'étrange civilisation aztèque
[Musique]
du plus lointain passé aux techniques
d'aujourd'hui voici la technique la plus
moderne que les chemins de fer français
utilisent pour le renouvellement de leur
voix écoutez bien on pense sur le
remblai une voie provisoire composé de
tronçons de 18 mètres à l'écartement
normal
grâce à cette voie provisoire on dépose
sur les traverses à l'extérieur des fils
de rails de 300 mètres qui constitueront
la voix définitive cette voie plus
larges que la normale est simplement
posé sans être fixé et voici l'opération
technique qui se réalise sous vos yeux à
l'aide de quatre chariots un chariot
réduit l'écartement des rails de la voie
provisoire laissant l'emplacement libre
pour la future voie ferrée
[Musique]
les fils de rails de 300 mètres
composant cette future bois sont alors
amenés à l'écartement normale est
définitif et tout en reculant le train
ramasse la voie provisoire désormais
sans objet ainsi la sncf poursuit-elle
la modernisation de toutes ces
installations
[Musique]
le boeuf et le boucher c'est un titre
qui fait songer à une fable or c'est un
drame est un problème le gouvernement
ayant devant la hausse kristek décidé la
taxation de la viande les bouchers ont
décidé de ne plus vendre de boeuf s'est
réduite à ces éléments de base la
question du jour la fièvre monte à la
police d'intervenir aux abattoirs de la
villette qui sont comme le thermomètre
de la boucherie et de l'élevage et les
bouchers se refusait à s'approvisionner
en boeufs
autre problème walt les entrepôts
frigorifiques on paie déjà soixante
mille tonnes de viande l'état devrait-il
se charger d'un surcroît de marchandises
que les bouchers se refusait à écouler
mais ce débat cache l'essentiel entre la
viande morte et la bête vivante pourquoi
cet écart qui multiplie par cinq le prix
d'achat sur pied
nous avons demandé à un éleveur ce qu'il
pense de ce mystère
d'emplois que d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
complètement je vends mes bêtes sur près
de 180 abonnement mombleau interviennent
en 370 francs le kilo de viande dans sa
tâche je m'étonne après seuls
consommateurs ne puissent pas trouver
des faits qu'à moins de 12 à 15 ans en
silence alors que préconisez vous
je trouve qu'il n'ya pas besoin de
quatre ou cinq personnes à temps sa
présence au masters et moi je
préfèrerais vendre et à une seule
organisation il s'occuperait de
l'abattage et la répartition le fait est
que entre l'éleveur et le push et on
compte quelques intermédiaires le petit
ramasseur qui vend un confrère plus
étoffé qui vend un chevillard de la
villette qui vend un grossiste qui
vendra aux bouchers
autre chose encore la vétusté des
installations et l'inorganisation de
l'industrie les sous-produits une
employée du temps de la marchandise est
de l'argent perdu
seul ici la réorganisation du circuit la
révolution clés du circuit court
l'abattoir industriel en plein pays
d'élevage résoudrait la question chemin
direct qui mène sans intermédiaire du
producteur aux bouchers ou aux
consommateurs traitement à la chaîne
sans perte d'où un prix de revient plus
bas
ces abattoirs en outre récupère et
utilise scientifiquement les déchets
rendant l'opération plus rentable
puisqu'elle supprime une charge
jusqu'ici supporté par le rosbif
dans les premiers supermarchés déjà chez
les bouchers un jour la ménagère
trouvera sous cellophane la viande de
notre circuit cool ce sera
l'approvisionnement moderne d'un pays
moderne qui dans ce domaine de la viande
en est resté à henry cap mais revenons à
la question du jour à cette bataille du
billeter selon les derniers
développements elle semble évoluer vers
l'apaisement à la salle wagram les
bouchers parisiens dont le leader
monsieur drucbert a déjà souvent
reparler de lui ont tenu une réunion
houleuse mais la raison peut quelquefois
se faire entendre même débouché en
colère et il semble avoir fait un pas et
même peut-être un geste
on attendait avec curiosité la rencontre
du stade français et de l'équipe
sedanaise leader inattendu du
championnat
et malgré le mauvais temps 25000
parisien était au parc des princes tout
de suite on peut constater que le stade
joué l'un de ses meilleurs matches c'est
lui en effet qui marquait coup sur coup
les deux premiers but à la 25e et à la
28e minute
ce dans les tills baisser les bras
devant la malchance non les ardennes et
au contraire allait maintenant se raidir
et entamé une contre attaque méritoire
qui grâce au tandem breni michel aller
avant la mi-temps réduire la marque
cinq minutes après la mi temps sedan
encouragé par son premier succès marqué
par faustino le second but égalisateur
[Applaudissements]
on pouvait croire que les sedanais remis
en selle allaient poursuivre leur
avantage le stade ne leur permit pas son
domicile à commarque nous dès lors la
partie était jouée l'énergie du
désespoir manifesté par sedan 9e valoir
qu'une nouvelle déception trois minutes
avant la fin bourbotte marquer un
quatrième but pour le stade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]